our eyes our window not to our soul
necessarily but
to our condition and
and research shows that uh there's
products out there using eye tracking
to to identify concussion and a dementia
and other
kind of cognitive issues and there's
research that shows that adhd
can be seen from my eyes which makes a
lot of sense if you think about it right
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctek
today i have the privilege of talking to
a world expert on one of the most
important topics
that is facing the younger generation
and the older generation for that matter
adhd meet adi diner ceo and co-founder
of ifocus
adi diner is the ceo and co-founder of
ifocus and a physicist phd with
extensive experience in product
development in the biotech and medical
device industries
1 in 10 children and adults have adhd
today the treatment relies only on
subjective feedback
do you feel it is working as a result
many do not get treated properly
eye focus will change the way adhd is
treated by providing objective treatment
efficacy measures adi diner from palo
alto welcome to 20 minute leaders how
are you
great thank you for having me here phd
in physics from the weitzman institute
albert systems about 10 more companies
that i'm not going to mention now
but you're working on on some of the
most exciting things that i can think of
uh with with a passion for for hardware
and biotech and medical devices and
today focusing on i focus as a
co-founder and ceo
talking about an ai-based medical device
in the adhd
space a lot of us a lot a lot of things
to unpack from
this very short and and i apologize in
advance bad
introduction but we're gonna talk about
uh
everything hopefully who are you adi
how how do you navigate through phd in
physics to medical devices to adhd
so i think the the the correlating line
is i like
to solve complex problems and i like to
do that use
actual data and you know scientific
approach to solve them
i think that takes the line through so
one thing you learn when you do
an experimental phd is you learn how to
figure out how to solve problems
in the uh and challenges because if you
just
guest work and shoot in the dark it's
not going to work
eh phd
so i was uh working at the weizmann
institute
in a pretty complex lab with
big vacuum systems and lasers and lots
of things that can break down
so the science is what is one thing but
you learn that most of the time
you tr you troubleshoot technical
problems right and so
as you go through then your journey to
albert systems what do you discover
about yourself
you know on your journey that you know
focuses you
on at the end biotech medical devices
and and your most recent venture
uh you know it's a good question but i i
think the first thing i learned
is that i'm pretty good in
uh communicating and not only doing the
work
so getting other people to do things
communicating
what should be done and kind of thinking
through the process and then i spent
i found myself in many companies i
worked in working on process of product
development
and defining the process and they
learned that many people don't want to
do that
why do you think so i think well
scientists and engineers want to do the
technical interesting part
and the people that are not don't want
to bother with you know
working with these crazy scientist
engineers
so having both sides is important
and i also learned that you know too
much process is
catastrophic no process at all is also
catastrophic so you need to find the
middle ground
and working with hardware it emphasizes
that because mistakes
are much more expensive both financially
and in terms of
time skill you can't just do an upgrade
with the customers in the field
right so to take me up 30 000 feet in
the air most of the
people that i get to talk to here
they're coming from the software space
i'd love to to understand a little bit
better hardware
and and the way that it works and and
you know the complexity behind
working on hardware especially in
biotech and medical devices
what what does the landscape look like
how does the how does this cycle work
you know perhaps as opposed to you know
traditional sas company
so there are a few kind of if i want to
hide at the differences that's
the middle of the dead the first step
is figuring out the technology and
solving technical problems is
fairly similar you know you iterate you
try to figure it out
there's another step that is a very
important hardware and i think less so
software is the translating what works
in the lab to something that you can
actually manufacture
so the fact that the engineer can work
on this for a month and make it to work
then you need to make it again right the
fact it worked once is still not good
enough and that's a huge challenge uh
and the other step is scaling right
uh if i can make 10 doesn't mean i can
make a hundred or i can make a thousand
and then you usually need a different
facility and a different process for
each of these steps
and that gets expensive and time
consuming especially if you don't plan
for it
right and so and so while it sounds to
me that today you know when we're
talking about scale at least in the
software
space you know we've been trained almost
and the ecosystem has moved towards this
you know one touch scale
and worst case you just pay a little bit
more but but the services
it doesn't require of you too much what
i'm hearing from you is that
is this added complexity of the supply
chain here in manufacturing that you
have to take into account when you're
working with hardware right
yes definitely and the cost of changes
right so you get to out to customers
right you want to do agile you go out to
the customers and customer tells you you
need to change something that's very
expensive
so you need to get creative with
figuring out how to
loop that information in before spending
all the time to get the final product
right now that makes a lot of sense to
me and so as you go throughout your
journey what what are some what are some
of the guiding points for you
when you decide on on what to work on
when to work on it because one of the
things that you know as a young
entrepreneur
i observe about myself and about others
is this constant question of
what is the right thing for me to be
doing and how do you answer that for
yourself
i have to say i've keep asking myself
what i want to do when i grow up
that seems to be a constant question
and it's changed the answer changes with
time
so the first step is kind of to let go
of working in the lab i love working in
the lab
but at some point you realize i value
more the big picture
and being involved involved in system
level and you know company level
decisions
and you can't do it from the lab you
can't do both uh so that was the first
step
um and then i wanted to see okay where
where can i i make an impact what can
actually do good in the world
that's fine no building lasers for
research is exciting
but and you can say yeah eventually it
will make
good in the world but it feels not
strong enough and that's what kind of
pulled me to
biotic and medical devices and building
a device that you actually know can help
people later
and save people's lives potentially i
that
makes me feel much more uh accomplished
or
it feels like i'm using my skills to
something that will actually help people
and you really want to do that makes
much more fun to go to work in the
morning
right and so you know what started from
what it seemed like a
consulting uh you know turned into more
now more of a you know concrete passion
with with
center around adhd so like i generally
like to do
let's start 30 000 feet in the air the
landscape of the of
of you know learning disabilities or
adhd
focus and then deep dive into what did i
focus actually do
yeah so what i'm doing now has nothing
to do with hardware actually
i know how hard it is and every time i
had an idea in the hardware space i
would disregard it because it was too
complicated
but it's interesting because a lot of
the lessons to
do work in software as well uh uh like
how important it is to define your
product correctly is a good example
uh but going back to to the high level
discussion
uh i i was diagnosed with adhd during my
phd
and my son two years ago hd yeah so
relatively late
career uh you know when i was studying
uh two exams in in college i would
physically walk around the table
but no i didn't ask why it was fine no i
was working with a group and just
walking around the table all the time
because i couldn't physically sit down
um and by the way women and girls are
the population that is most
missed in diagnosing adhd because uh
they tend to be less distract disruptive
type and more the dreamy type
and if it doesn't bother anyone then
it's not addressed
uh that's that's a different part and
and uh
and and women's health is and and how
that's been missed because research was
done on men is a big topic that i'm not
an expert in
we could have a few episodes i think
just on that
but going back to adhd so one thing that
a
kept running in my mind throughout you
know kind of as i was learning about
adhd
is the amount of misconceptions
that are out there and the fact that
there's not enough data so the best way
in my mind to fight misconceptions is to
have strong data and there's no data
a diagnosis is done mostly by
questionnaires and discussion there's
some automated testing
but in the end the doctor needs to make
call so there's no
do this blood test or imaging or
whatever and get a result
and treatment is even worse you get
whichever treatment you decide to try
the way the doctor knows it works is
they ask you
or the parents teachers parents or
teachers
that's the only tool and if i during my
phd when i was diagnosed
kept thinking or maybe i'm just lazy
everyone that has a hard time
focusing you know and i was already
accomplished how can you expect
teenagers to to be confident with that
answer
yeah so i kept thinking of
for a while now what would be a good way
to collect more data
and then a kind of the immediate way to
think about it is mris i know there's
work to reduce the cost of mris but it's
still way off
having everyone be able to do an mri is
is just not there yet
i know people here that you know in the
israel at least in israeli medical
system you want to get an mri great we
have an appointment for you for two and
a half months from now
and you better get ready yeah so there's
enough work on improving that
but that's a long time skill
and then actually it's a funny story
it's you know because we all move to
zoom
i realize teachers can't know if the
kids are falling
right because you have 20 kids or more
and
that's because they can't see the kids
eyes right so i started looking at
research on this topic
and i learned yes our eyes our window
not to our soul necessarily but
to our condition and
and research shows that there's products
out there
using eye tracking to identify
concussion and
a dementia and other kind of cognitive
issues
and there's research that shows that
adhd can be seen
from your eyes which makes a lot of
sense if you think about it right
right now mean that makes a lot of sense
and so
when you make when at that point in time
in the intersection you have that
understanding you have the discovery
you're you're at an inflection point you
have to decide what to do
what do you have to what do you do with
that information so what do you do andy
so first of all i you know i was looking
you know of course
my initial topic someone should have
thought about it it's out there no
someone did it
so i did some research i found something
that were close but
no one really took it to the direction
i'm thinking of because
in a way the advantage i'm not i'm not a
psychiatrist i don't come from this
field
so i can see things slightly differently
i'm also not a researcher so i'm not
trying to understand the mind
there are people that do that way better
than that right i'm trying to get to uh
and i saw no one else did it
i also something else as being a
consultant working with many startups
i realized that you know there are great
startups and startups that seem to be
maybe not amazing right so you have all
the range and the way
i can do what they can do right
i love that and and so you when as
you're saying i can do what they can do
what is actual course of action what is
the plan to tackle this
and you know both at scale but you know
at the end to to make a positive impact
so i started talking with people and the
first an amazing
uh advice i got is talk to a hundred
people
uh darya henning shaquille gave me that
advice talk to 100 people
which is amazing because it's a process
you learn more as you talk to people
and you get a better understanding of
what you want and how you're going to
communicate it
i talk to people from the field to
potential customers to parents lots of
parents
you know people with adhd
and people from my eye tracking space as
well so understand between the eye
tracking
kind of going back to my optics and the
uh background
so that's nice it's always there to to
support
uh and i managed to get a eye tracker
from the leading
eye tracking company a toby pro a for a
month
uh and one month is not a lot to learn
about the new technology
but it was a good challenge and
because there are quite a few
entrepreneurs and talented people with
adhd i managed to get
10 people around to help me test my
theory
so we had them read with and without
medication a paragraph
here at the garage i'm saying starting
in the garage in palo alto
it's always a good start and then that's
always good that's half the battle
honestly
and honestly it was amazing so you know
the summit was adults and teens so the
the kid is reading i have the parents
standing behind me and you can see the
monitor
with me and you can see how much harder
the kids are working without medication
and these are extremely successful high
schoolers right
right but without medication you can see
they're going up and down
reading again and again and with
medication this
it's just going and the amazing thing is
if you would have
asked them is it hard to read this
paragraph without medication
they would laugh at me right this was a
middle school little paragraph they read
books for fun so they don't know they're
working so much harder
and that's the amazing thing here that
was the the real kind of aha moment
it's you can see the difference without
making the other side working so hard
and failing a test if you want right
and it makes it makes it so much easier
to make medical decisions
and for parents to kind of get behind
these decisions but they said it's
really effective
it's making it's making my kids life
easier right
and so as you're going through this aha
moment and
you know we also have to give the
context this is all pretty recent right
i mean he started this back in around
january so this has only
been going on for a few months and so
it's especially an interesting time to
talk to you about this because
this is a you know right when it's
happening
how do you go about you know envisioning
a world
after i focus has has made its
dent how is the world different after i
focus
rather than before i focus so you know
today if someone has high blood pressure
for example the first thing that the
doctor will do is send you good
device to measure your heart blood
pressure and measure it before you take
the first treatment and after before
that no one talks to you without it
and blood pressure is a good example
because there's fluctuations the fact
that you had the measurement at the
clinic is not
a medical decision concentration is the
same
right we all know that not every day is
the same uh
so the way i vision it would be the same
right you have this device it's
a go to webcam based
you software you go home you run the
test a few times on your computer
and or your kid runs the test and then
you try
first medication and you can see if it
works there's no guesswork
the stress that every parent okay which
adhd feels
of did they make the right decision goes
away
or reduces significantly right as
parents always have a stress but it
reduces significantly
and then you think something changed or
you go to a generic medicine because you
change insurance
no stress you just try it again right
right i want this affected by your
child's diagnosis
of course that was a big trigger for
thinking through this so so
as i was kind of thinking if i focus we
were also thinking about starting
medication with my son
uh and and we have started
and i would love to have this tool now i
have the advantage that i'm taking
medication so i know how it looks
and luckily he's been reacting similarly
to the way i have which is not a given
um but
and and it's been we've been relatively
lucky with with low side effects but
that's not the average you know many
people have a hard time finding the
right medication
uh and i would definitely want to know
right as he's becoming more of a
teenager right he's 12 now
he will tell me less about how he feels
and how school goes
and teachers are great but
they they are not they can't
know exactly what experience every
student has
right they can see if something is
falling apart and you want to catch it
before falling apart
and there's an important point to
understand about adhd
the way i see it is that what stops
people
with a moderate adhd kind of
average from succeeding is not adhd
it's losing confidence in their ability
and and school is a bad environment for
adhd because
you have to concentrate on something
that is not interesting for you
in many cases right in life we all try
to
at least spend most of our time with
things that are interesting for us in
school you can't do that
and so you put the kids there and that's
where they define
their the way they see themselves
and how they perceive their capability
now if you don't think you can there's
no way you succeed
i i love that the context that you're
framing this says
you know a motivate in motivation in the
context of if curiosity
not just the context of how fast you can
read or or how many problems you can
solve in an hour but it's
it's all about it then this intrinsic
motivation to learn and
i i want to thank you for coming and
sharing with me this marvelous journey
and
and i just love this idea that you're
getting the this
amazing domain expertise in in in
different fields
from physics to hardware to biotechnical
devices but then translating to
something that you're innately
passionate about
20 20 minutes go by very very fast but i
have three
quick and fun questions for you if
you're ready okay
all right favorite subject in middle
school or high school
i think i know what it is yeah it's it
was physics but only the lab part
not the theory only the only the lab
part somebody who inspires you
a role model of yours gosh i i think all
the women that are
uh broke the glassing at the ceiling
every each and every one of those
i love that i that that's a really good
one and
three words that you would choose to
describe yourself or if i were to ask
anybody who is adi dinero
who are you a gosh that's a hard one uh
yeah because i'm a a mother
i'm a i think i'm a researcher
in heart and not in the academic sense
but i like learning new things
and that looks really persistent i love
that adi
thank you very very much thank you very
much continue doing amazing things and
then
making a positive impact on the world
thank you thank you very much
take care
[Music]